let's go next to our caller from the
8:06 area code who's calling today from
8:06 hello is me yes it is
oh hello David Pakman on my name is
peridot I'm I'm a recent listener you
know my friend told me about the show
because I want to learn more about
politics yeah were you for thank you for
taking my spot all well I'm in Texas
right now but I'm originally from
Colombia you know what part of Cologne
Iowa oh you know the capital you know
but anyway so I've been watching the
election recently and you know I'm
really upset about the caucus you know
well so I guess my question and you know
they're listening like some other
results but like do you know why they
didn't just way to like to release them
all I want you know well there's two
points of view on that one is that
releasing nothing until they have 100
percent would be even more embarrassing
because it could be like five days so
that's one pot that's the most innocent
explanation a more conspiratorial
explanation would be they've had close
to 100% of the results for a while but
they selected 62% initially later 71
percent that were favorable to Pete
Budaj edge to give him a round of news
headlines that's the more conspiratorial
point of view I don't know the answer to
be quite honest better okay all right
just like watching like a hundred
percent yes I don't get why they're like
talking about it and like they don't
have the full result you know yes we are
all concerned about this and it is a big
ball drop and you know I think Iowa
doesn't even deserve to go first I think
the first to vote should be a primary
anyway not a caucus and I think that
this disaster in Iowa justifies saying
in 2024 there's no Iowa goes first
anymore
oh yeah you know I don't even like I
didn't even know where I oh well you
know okay I'm trying to understand like
where the country is and everything
nothing's I've been here how long have
you been in the Oh
I've been here you know two years now
you know
I've been wanting to do like come here
for a long time you know you know I said
what happened you know when you have a
wife and a kid it kind of talked you
know and they came with you but anyway
oh yeah my wife you know she doesn't
really like we're not doing too good
right now together you know I still love
my my wife and my kids and my aunt
Lyanna 13 I'm telling the like this
country and you or I would are you
interested in going back to Colombia oh
no no no no you know dick would say here
you know got it but all right there are
a real pleasure con gusto I I appreciate
the phone call
well thank you David Pakman okay but all
right we'll talk to Pedro later very
interesting phone call
let's take a quick break don't hang up
if you are holding we will go right back
to the phones after this short break